this morning
[Music]
hours
foreign
this is these will be uh no doubt of
decisive importance because these coming
weeks
you said we must continue to divide
maximum level of support three main
areas of the military field we have
spoken about this on many occasions over
recent weeks
and during the European Council you were
able to make your points it was very
clear and straightforward terms to the
European leaders and of course
informal contacts as well talking about
the military needs what you need to help
you defend and protect the Integrity
of Ukraine artillery Municipal defense
systems
exactly what you need and what you need
no that's the first one secondly you
come here
foreignty of Ukraine we will spare no
efforts day after days
I spoke that I spoke about this a few
days ago
you have chosen
followed the choice of the Ukrainian
people
and I think we can be very proud of the
fact that the European leaders decided
so quickly to Grant candidate status to
Ukraine for a EU membership since then
despite the ongoing War you have
bravely
great determination implemented in forms
we are very impressed that we've made in
just a few months
after the summer there will be a report
from the European commission my
responsibility will be to ensure that
the council lives up to its
responsibilities by the end of this year
on the basis of the commission report we
can decide on the follow-up to this
will maintain its determination to put
pressure on the Kremlin sanctions are
still on the table the tense sanctions
packages being discussed we want to take
a consistent firm approach we want to
ensure that those who are guilty of
crimes can be held to account for those
crimes including from crime aggression
and that is why we have the initiatives
to collect evidence
so that we can enable International
Justice to remove impunity in this
respect we want to ensure
we can also take the appropriate
for Europeans who had been traumatized
by the two tragic world wars which have
devastated the European continent all of
us here
through our families our parents our
grandparents who lived through the
horrors of the second world war
they saw the European project peace and
prosperity as the key to a better future
these are the key to our European
projects and
we need to take the right decisions to
ensure that peace and prosperity can
remain the key values of the European
project
these can hold sway across all of Europe
in the coming decades we are absolutely
determined and I would just say in
conclusion speaking here in Brussels I
would like to repeat what I said a few
weeks ago in addressing the Ukrainian
Parliament and the Ukrainian people of
the European Union
Ukraine is the European Union the
European Union is our common home and we
will mobilize all our efforts together
Ukraine
long live here thank you Mr president
president zielinski you have the floor
numbers
ladies and gentlemen dear journalists
of the European leaders the Ukrainian
language is part of the European
discussion
Ukrainian language is part of the
European Parliament
is a part indeed
European practice
oh dear president I would like to thank
you for the joint efforts of the
Ukrainian government and the European
Commission
in our state where we discussed not just
our issues of Defense but our future
our movement and our integration
the defense and protection of our
everyday life and everything and our
values I'm absolutely sure not just
Ukrainian what are the European values
as well
I've just participated in the meeting of
the European Council yes it was the
closed meeting but I want you to
understand this and to get the feeling
of what we discussed and this sense was
defined by one of the leaders of the
European Union who said that the long
term in Europe will
[Music]
and Ukraine will become the part of the
European Union
our discussions in Brussels
very precise we were talking about
security we were talking about these
savings lives and stability we were
talking about the return of justice and
these values are not just your great
values their European values as well
we have discussed this
Ukraine used to export the electricity
to the European Union
we were making your social life uh your
welfare uh
dependence
Russia has occupied and switched from
the network our nuclear power stations
that is the violation of your interests
values yes but also the interest and we
can talk about every single element of
the Russian aggression in the same way
yes they are trying to destroy our
economy and our cities
of our dangerous attacks
I have been very inspired by your
statements that Europe will be with us
until our Victory I've heard it from a
number of the European leaders
I've heard about the Readiness to give
us a necessary weapons and support
including the aircrafts and I will have
a number by letters now and we are going
to raise the issue of the fighter jets
and other aircraft so we are working and
continue to work in Brussels I want to
thank all of you
the citizens of the European Union for
all your support
for the way you support our people for
giving us the Refuge The Refuge and the
shelter for the Ukrainian citizens who
were trying to protect their children
from the bombs but millions of our
citizens are Now supported in Europe and
I hope that your citizens could see that
the European values are real thank you
very much for this thank you for
everything friends
that's the only way I can address you
friends thank you and glory to Ukraine
[Applause]
thank you Mr President Madam president
you have the floor thank you
thank you
thank you thank you for coming to the
heart of the European Union
thank you for the strong message we
heard from you
your fight is a fight for independence
for democracy for free Europe
and I did not only hear your strong and
powerful message in the European
Parliament but also here in the European
Council
and I've heard your urgency
we all heard the urgency of your call to
support Ukraine now
you spoke in a very moving manner
about and praising the European way of
life
and you added
that ukrainians want to come home to
this European way of life
and indeed today you see we are one
family
we have one vision
and family members help each other
you can count on us
we will continue to provide our full
support
now
to sustain your people through this
atrocious war and for the future
ukrainians are giving their lives for
free and independent Ukraine
they are fighting for the respect of our
common values
and we know that we can never match the
sacrifices ukrainians are making every
single day
but we can stand up for you
one figure that puts it into perspective
is 67 billion
67 billion of support we have mobilized
in the last 12 months from budget
support to fast recovery from energy
Supply to military capabilities from
humanitarian Aid to Refugee support and
we must do more
this I think is also the urgency we took
away today as a message from you and we
must do more we are supporting Ukraine
to win this war
and we are making sure that Ukraine wins
the peace that will come
it must be a just peace
we fully back your peace formula the
evolutomia
the European Union is working with its
Partners to support Ukraine across the
10 points of your peace formula
from Economic Security on nuclear safety
food security energy among others
and we will work hard to ensure the
broadest possible Global support for it
a just piece also means accountability
this brings me to my second Point Russia
must pay for the destruction caused
and for the blood spilled
in the next case we will propose the
10th package of sanctions
first we will impose sanctions on a
number of political and military leaders
but also the evolutomir we listened very
carefully to your messages when we
visited you last week in Kiev
we will Target Putin's propagandrists
because their lies
are poisoning the public space in Russia
and abroad you were insisting on that we
hear you we will follow up and we're
going after them
secondly the package will include
additional exports ban worse more than
10 billion euros this will further
starve Russia's military machine and
continue to shake the foundation
of its economy
and the International Community is also
working hard to ensure that Justice is
served
three steps are important
the first one is that we collect and
store evidence of the crimes being
committed we have already started
the second step is
to have prosecutors work together
for that we are setting up the center in
The Hague
and the next step is
to set up a Tribunal
here the discussions are ongoing about
the exact structure but I assure you
valarumia
we have the political will
to hold the perpetrator accountable
including
for the crime of aggression
and there is the political will so we
must find a way
finally
on our common future
Ukraine's youth is fighting for their
sovereign country
too many are paying the ultimate price
but their dreams lives on
dreams of a new Ukraine not only free
Democratic and European but also fair
and green and prosperous
we are already laying the groundwork
we have built the Reconstruction
platform with which has gone live now
our partners start seconding experts to
the Secretariat
which we're hosting in Brussels and in
Kiev
the response to our call is amazing our
cities are joining too
36 European cities from Vilnius to
Venice will work with 10 cities in
Ukraine like khakif
this is the living proof of the enormous
support you have all over the European
Union
and as you said every single person
comes you said it very powerfully in the
European Parliament it's as the
politicians yes but every single person
in the European Union counts
to contribute to support Ukraine
Ukraine has Advantage advancing on its
urine European path in an impressive
manner
accession is a merits-based process
and your track record shows
that you are able to deliver fast
and of high quality
even as you fight an aggressor
even as you are at War
I hear Ukrainian people so often speak
about their hopes
they want their children to grow up in
the European Union
and this hope gives them the strength to
cope with this horrible War
mer between now
and this bright future
that may be a hard Road To Tread but
rest too short
that we will be with you along every
step of the way
let's turn ukrainians dreams into
reality into the European way of life
and since the beginning of my mandate
I have concluded every single speech
with the words Long Live Europe
since one year for a good purpose
we add to the term long live Europe
always Slava Ukraine
[Applause]
thank you madam presidents we'll take a
few questions first but from the
Ukrainian media soriana you had a
question from Radio free Europe
uh good afternoon everyone so obviously
my first question is to Ukrainian
president so if you don't mind
colleagues I will switch into Ukrainian
language uh Vladimir Alexander is
we have seen the result of your visit to
Britain after this the British prime
minister has announced a training for
Ukrainian Pilots
Ukraine could potentially get the
fighter jet they would be trained to
prepare that was quite a concrete
announcement and when you met in Paris
and French president there were no
concrete promises does it mean that they
were not announced publicly or they
didn't happen so perhaps you could share
those decisions with us and also you've
had the meeting with 27 leaders of the
European Union and also but the
representative of the European
institutions the
and also long-range missiles has Ukraine
got any closer after this meeting that
was a representative question to the
Ukrainian president of European
commission I would like to address you
uh so you mentioned this topic apart
from the weapon another crucial topic
right here is the future membership of
Ukraine in the European Union uh so as
far as we know the first official
assessment of the implementation of
seven criteria is about to come in the
late 2023 and Ukraine Council getting
the decision on opening the accession
talks uh the same year I mean 2023 so
how could you estimate the old Center
the possibilities to open the accession
talks especially in 2023 and is it
possible that in addition to these seven
so-called additions would be added new
ones thank you
can answer
long long question
I will answer in Ukraine in Ukraine and
if it's possible um
I think that our visit to London has
achieved results and we have moved
towards the dissolutions concerning the
long-range missiles and the training of
our Pilots yes indeed that is an
important road to uh getting the fighter
jets which we need also there are
certain agreements which are not public
but are positive
when
these items will happen in our state uh
our state will know this but I don't
want to prepare the Russian Federation
which constantly uh threads us with the
new aggression concerning Paris and the
meeting with the president uh macro and
Chancellor Schultz we had
I would say a very powerful meeting a
very important amazing and
um I will see this meeting as a positive
one and talking about concrete decisions
indeed I would not want to announce many
things publicly but all I can say is
that we were working towards the
enhancement of our capabilities when we
talk about the offensive we are talking
about the armored equipment and we are
talking about the tanks and I have
received a positive impression from our
meeting
when we talk about the meeting with the
27 leaders well first of all we have to
understand that Britain France earned 27
countries of the EU and the European
Union and Leadership and indeed the
Society of the European Union
all deserve a huge gratitude from us
from our state so one of the reasons why
I'm here is I have to thank for all the
figures for all the words which were
mentioned in concrete steps which were
mentioned today these are the concrete
measures to support our society and to
support our displaced citizens and our
economy as well that all supported our
resilience resilience of the state means
the Army and the Army resident Army
means the Victory and that is of course
the only result we all see
and thanks God for that talking about
the results of the meeting uh when we
talk about the meetings we indeed
took place we still have a number of
bilaterals we are working and it's a
working order in process thank you very
very quick first point I'm absolutely
confident that this meeting is an
occasion for many many EU leaders to
make very clear that they are ready to
provide more military support and we all
understand the urgency of this need for
more Military Support 0.1 and 0.2 the EU
enlargement process I am confident
because we we observed the recent weeks
and Men how you train very quickly
demonstrated the ability to implement
reforms that are extremely important and
to make progress it means that we we
know what will happen in the following
weeks Ukraine will continue to implement
Reformatory needed 0.1 the commission
will make a report and the council will
have to decide what are the next steps
by the end of the year
the commission is indeed working very
closely with the Ukrainian government on
the progress in the candidate's status
and the seven steps and of course these
seven steps and not more referring to
your question because we have agreed on
these ones
um it is impressive to see how highly
professional with enormous quality
Ukraine is advancing on doing the
necessary reforms and working on these
seven steps for example the adoption of
the anti-corruption strategy the
resumption of the high judicial Council
the New Media law or these are steps
absolutely in the right direction more
needs to be done but important is to
understand there is no rigid timeline it
is a merits-based process so it's up to
the candidate country how far and how
fast they reach the goals that are being
set indeed there will be an oral report
now in Spring but the big goal is
um to show the progress and to show the
track record in the progress and the
reforms to the report the written report
enlargement report in fall that's our
common goal the commission is of course
supporting Ukraine as much as possible
and Advising as much as possible in this
question I think it's very helpful that
we have now the Secretariat in Brussels
and in Kiev because from the very
beginning it was clear that when we move
forward now in fast recovering we
repair later on in reconstruction that
Investments should be coupled with
reforms that pave the past towards the
European Union
Elizabeth from
Ukraine info yes please
hello colleagues first
Ukraine as well
[Music]
and dear uh I would like to ask you a
question about our armed forces of
Ukraine
you know that our volunteer volunteers
are armed forces
we cooperate quite closely with the
European Council and also with European
Union
but unfortunately not
everybody in the European Union
sometimes feels uh you know that the
country is at War there are some
entertainment facilities working and
they keep forgetting about the hell of
Bahamut at other places and I wanted to
ask you when do you feel the whole
country and the society will actually
start feeling that the countries that
war together with the Armed Forces
foreign
thank you very much for this question
I think we shouldn't mix everything
together
it's very difficult to wage war for such
a long time and we have very very
grateful to our divorces and not just as
this who are on the front line
but of course we have a grateful to them
because they're giving their lives but
also those who are Waging War working
not just in the front line they were
they have to pay taxes people are
supporting the army so indeed People Are
People humans are humans and there are
people who are tired to work in this
Machines of course the psychological
issues there are people who already need
Rehabilitation there are those who are
lost was somebody close to them or
relatives there are those who want to
forget
that they are grieving people are humans
they're different and I think that's a
component of Our Lives we cannot treat
everybody the same way we can't say you
all absolutely must
people have to have a Consciousness
conscious of that they have to
understand it themselves there I agree
with you totally people have to
understand that unfortunately
the war continues
unfortunately
[Music]
it depends from our unity and our Unity
will give the resilience to our soldiers
there are people who want to on holiday
arrest there are occasions there are
people not there are challenges but we
are not talking about millions of people
who don't want to support and of course
it's not just our case it happened
during various Wars therefore the
information support is key and the
president has to show with his own
example how you should behave during the
war the journalists have to show
um if somebody decides perhaps to go on
holiday rather than support a war effort
yes this is our common goal common work
but please don't forget we are all
humans
and by the way those humans we are all
humans who managed to stop Russian
aggression and we are now at the most
important stage we have stopped it but
now we have to win and we can't do it
just by words saying oh why the martial
law and we can't concentrate everybody's
attention through the words we have to
work we have to give information we have
to look at every door and we have to do
it together
I feel that it's not just the issue of
the military or the information policy
or indeed the government I think these
are the key steps
we are the Democratic state so we have
to understand we have to develop and we
are defending our democracy we can't
force people to well we are not Russia
that is the Paradox we are fighting for
the European values we want to be the
member of the European Union so even
when we fight we have to fight with
dignity and with those values thank you
yeah they're in the back
um hello Mr President
um first of all problems
I have two questions if I may on
Ukraine's integration process in
European Union first according to
president wonderlane here you're making
good progress but you accept that
Ukraine will likely have to wait years
before it can be a full member of the EU
and that within Europe there are
different level of supports toward
Ukraine and secondly what kind of EU
would you like to see and contribute to
I have a closer Union where Brazil takes
most decisions with no vetoes Union
where nations are firmly in the lead
thank you so much
I had transitions
everything is for me
I'm very welcome
I see
um
and and also not sad that we we I think
I thought maybe I wanted to hear
maybe we want too much but anyway so up
I think I heard that will will
after the recommendation the result
about our recommendations and and we can
start opening the dialogue about our
future
uh or in in EU
yes and you know my question is to
everybody
we need Unity
in this case so and and that's why of
course we need the the this year we want
very much to motivate us and to motivate
by the way to motivate our army because
they you know they attacked by by
Russians and by all this aggression to
motivate we are fighting for and we need
these four and one of these very
important four of course sovereignty of
course Ukraine children homes and of
course membership
and that's why of course we need
this year and this year Charles when I
say this year I mean this year and
there's
two two zero 23. I feel I feel very well
responsibility of getting anonymity in
the European Council which will do our
best
question because we have to start at
some point with European Council again
yes Effie from uh from Euro News
uh thank you president and welcome to
Brussels so I would like to insist to
the Practical part of of all these
meetings so you mentioned fighter jets
but I would like to ask you how
satisfied are you by of the level of
delivery of weapons and Arms by the EU
so far and what would be your
expectations from today's meeting and I
mean is it just a high symbolism visit
or you expect to get some very concrete
promises for fighter jets or other stuff
by your EU counterparts and also for the
presidents uh do you see a common ground
for providing this kind of work planes
to Ukraine uh being reached anytime soon
and is it still this a decision to be
taken at a new level thank you
foreign
thank you very much for the question
I haven't got the right I simply haven't
got the right to come back home without
the results
that depends on the partners and from me
personally and for me it's very
important
we conduct and lead to the results
should lead to the result and perhaps
that's slightly impertinent but that's
not cynical that's pragmatic point of
view and I have to believe there are no
emotions the emotions are left on the
24th of February last year we are just
programmatic for us to survive we need
the weapons we need these weapons and
that's what I'm talking about for us to
survive we need these Financial funds
and I am not trying to hide behind the
words when I say we are defending our
common values I'm absolutely sure and I
hope that you understand that when you
help Ukraine you're helping yourselves
and you have to make it in such a way
that later
you shouldn't understand it in a
practical way so that later you don't
have to defend yourselves so please it's
important to give this assistance
earlier this is my Approach and let's
see of course there are positive signals
concerning the irrespective weapons we
have got positive signals that we hear
each other and I really want their
signals to move to concrete sounds
concrete voice the voice that is not
afraid that Russia will hear this voice
I'm absolutely sure that the countries
of the European Union and during this
year moved from doubts but have
significantly moved to a more grown-up
approach more powerful approach we need
your powerful voice we need your
powerful concrete support
foreign
decision of the member states of course
there's a strong coordination but and
you have seen the living proof of
delivery of military capabilities but
everything else
is done and coordinated at the European
level so the 67 billion for the past are
simple for that as I said we need to do
more and we will do more
um be it the economy be the integration
of the Ukrainian economy in the single
Market be it energy beat the solidarity
Lanes be it the support for the
ukrainians that are freeing Putin's
bombs and are in the European Union this
is all topics that are being pushed
forwards including the sanctions on the
European level that we are working on
but the delivery of military
capabilities is a sovereign decision of
the member states
thank you to the three presidents
president zielinski to you and your team
safe travels
foreign